You're standing at a
traffic intersection.
And you start to accelerate
when the light turns green.
Suppose that your acceleration
as a function of time
is a constant for some time
interval t less than t one.
And after that, it's zero for
a time after t one less than t
less than some time t two.
At the exact same instant
the light turns green,
a bicyclist is coming
through the intersection.
And the bicyclist has
some initial speed
and is braking with an
acceleration of minus
b two for the entire
time interval t two.
And at time t two,
the bicyclist comes
to rest exactly where
you are located.
And we also know some
initial conditions.
So our initial conditions
in this problem
are that you're accelerating
b one at a rate two
meters per second squared.
And you do this for time
t one equals one second.
And the bicyclist comes
into the intersection.
We'll call that b two naught.
That's the initial
speed of the bicyclist
at three meters per second.
And the question is, what
is the rate of deceleration
of the bicyclist b two?
Now this can be quite
a complicated problem.
So the first thing we want
to do is just make a sketch
and think about what's involved.
This problem
involves two objects.
You and the bicyclist.
The person-- that's you--
has two stages of motion.
And the bicyclist only
has one stage of motion.
So to get started,
it always helps
to choose a coordinate
system and to make
some sketches of the problem.
So let's say we choose a-- it's
all one dimensional motion.
Two objects.
One dimensional motion.
And so we'll pick an origin
at the light at the one
side of the intersection.
And we have two objects
which we'll talk about.
You, x one.
And the bicycle is x two.
Actually we don't know yet
who's in front of the other.
The bicyclist will be
first in front of you.
So now how do we
sketch the motion
of these two stages of motion?
So let's make a sketch.
And let's start with the person.
Well, the person-- if we
plotted their position
as a function of time-- this
would be position in general.
I'll just draw the
person function.
They're accelerating
to time t one.
And then they're moving at a
constant speed at time t two.
Now the bicyclist is a
little more complicated.
Because initially the bicyclist
has a-- this at time t,
person one.
Initially the bicyclist
has a non-zero slope.
And they're decelerating.
And they reach you
with a zero slope.
So this graph,
this is the x two.
That is the bicyclist.
And right here we
have the person.
x one.
So now to build a strategy,
we can even look at our graph
and see that from our
initial conditions,
we have some special conditions
that the-- our strategy will
be to-- one-- figure
out what this time is.
And we know that the
bicyclist at time t two
has come to a stop.
So that's one condition.
And we also know
that the bicyclist
comes to stop exactly at the
same position as the person.
x one of t two equals
x two of t two.
So those are two
conditions that we
can deduce from all of
this given information.
And now we comply our
kinematic relationships
for both the bicyclist
and the person
and try to see if these
conditions will enable
us to deduce what b two is.
So let's begin
with the bicyclist.
So the velocity of the
bicyclist as a function of time
is simply the integration
of that bicyclist b t
prime from zero to t two.
This is one stage of motion.
The acceleration is minus b two.
So this is a very
straightforward interval.
This is just b of two t two.
b two.
This is minus the initial
speed equals that.
b of t two minus V of
the initial is that.
And because we want
this to be zero,
we have the condition
that t two equals
V two naught divided by b two.
So that's our first
condition for the bicyclist.
Now we have to separately solve
for the bicyclist's position.
That's easy.
x two of t is the integral of V
two t prime dt prime from zero
to t two.
And that's just minus one half.
We want to make sure that
we get the displacement.
But x two naught is zero.
So we have x two at t two equals
the integral of the velocity
function, which is V
two naught minus b two
of t prime, d t prime
from zero to t two.
And so we get b two naught
t two minus one half b two t
two squared.
And when we input this
condition in for t two,
this becomes very simply V two
naught squared over two b two.
Substituting t two into
each of these expressions
gives us that relationship.
So that's the position of
the cyclist at time t two.
Now this is a
little bit trickier
to get the position
of the person.
So in order to do that,
we first find the velocity
of the person function.
It's a two stage motion.
So for the first stage
of motion, the velocity
two-- the velocity
of person one--
minus their initial velocity,
which is zero minus one zero.
That's zero.
Equals the integral of
b one dt prime from zero
to t one, which is
just b one t one.
And this velocity
remains constant
throughout the next interval.
So we can write the velocity
function in the following way.
V one t equals b one t for zero
less than t less than t one.
And afterwards, a
constant velocity.
Now this is the function
that we need to integrate
to get the displacement.
So let's get ourselves a little
room here and integrate that.
And we have x of t
is two integrals.
First from zero to
t one, the velocity
function during
that time interval.
And then for the second
time interval dt two,
the velocity function is
constant b-- this is b one.
b one t one, dt prime.
Notice this is not a variable.
But it is the time at
the end of the interval.
And when we make
these two intervals,
we get one half b
one t one squared.
Let's make this the
velocity at time t.
This first integral
goes from zero to t one.
And the second
interval, we're going
to make this the
position at time t two.
And we get plus V one times t
one times t two minus t one.
We have a common term, t
one squared, b, one half b
one t one squared.
b one minus b one,
t one squared.
So this reduces to one
half b one t one squared
plus b one, t one, t two.
And that's how we
find the position
of the person for our interval.
Let's just review
that to make sure.
Because we had to get the
velocity function first.
And then we integrated the
velocity in each time interval
correctly in order to get
the position function.
Now we can apply our conditions.
Notice we already
know t two here.
And we can now apply
the second condition
which says that the position
of the bicyclist at time t two,
which we found to be d
naught squared over two b two
is equal to the position of
the person at that same time.
So that's minus one half b one
t one squared plus b one t one.
Now let's make that
substitution for time t two.
So that's V two
naught over b two.
And now our problem is to
solve for this time b two.
And we're given b one.
We're given t one.
We're given V two naught.
And the only variable
here is b two.
It's a little bit of
algebra to rearrange terms.
What I'll do is I'll bring
this term over to here.
So now we'll just do a
little bit of algebra.
We have to a b two
we can pull out.
I have a minus b one
t one b two naught.
And that's equal to minus
one half b one t one squared.
And now I can solve for b two.
And so I get b two
is equal to Vt naught
squared minus b one t one b two
naught over minus one half b
one t one squared.
Now let's just do a
quick dimensional check.
b times t has the
dimensions of velocity.
So this is velocity
squared, velocity squared.
That's OK upstairs.
b times t squared is
dimensions of position.
So what we have is meters
squared per second squared
divided by meters.
That gives us meters
per second squared.
So we're pretty confident
that we at least didn't
make an algebraic mistake.
And now our last step is to
substitute in the numbers.
And what we get is, if we
put in the three meters
a second squared minus b
one times t one times three,
we get upstairs is minus 3/2.
And downstairs is
two times one second.
Two's cancel.
So we get to 3/2 meters
per second squared
when we put in the numbers.
If we wanted to
check our result,
we can then see
what time we get.
t two is is three meters per
second divided by our b two
which is 3/2 meters
per second squared.
So that's 2 seconds.
And now the last check would
be to see that the position
functions correspond to that.
Let's see if we can just do
that quickly in our heads.
Our position function
for the person
is V naught squared
over two b two.
So that's 9 meters per second.
9 meters squared seconds
squared over two times
3/2 meters second squared.
And that comes
out to x two of t.
This is a check, is 3 meters.
And the x one of t.
We left out the one there.
We should have had it.
It's a little more
complicated to put in here.
But we'll just run the
numbers quickly through.
Two times one seconds minus.
That's a minus one.
Two times one times two.
That's two times two.
So this is also three meters.
And we actually have
the right answer here.